prognosis the Rolls Royces throws off
strong the rolls-royce of strong so what
made you come up with this this high-end
baby lion I mean the parents we we like
to be stylish so one of the key I like
when everybody are happy on the street
and I think this good clothing
it's really make you smile especially on
a baby which I put here that's nice one
oh man yeah name is man yeah you're
right you're right you're right he'll
i'ma start selling baby wrap clothes
this is ultra tear dress and it's just
hundred dollars she's exams it does this
a real role but they can smell if you
won't have smells haha maybe real rows
of them 600 local value that's nice
I just see my little harmony walking in
this is nice
five hundred dollars for this one five
hundred uh you feel has smile but I have
smile that's my last price to put is
five hundred
no no yeah yeah what is 500 more also on
that show oh I see big that is so
elegant I love that doctor [ __ ] I need
this [ __ ] I have people in beards on
stage even where this movie like you're
so Starla Jukes young you pick up
so here we have van Gogh stroller and
this is a real van Gogh
you know printing is not yes and this is
$1,400 this is 14 yes yeah this is what
you get for 40 now because it's van gone
this is thank you oh my god it has flour
on it and and you can imagine how it
smells nice well it's scratch a still
here we have Roy source of strollers
this is stroller which is used for 140
years so this total cost over $5,000 but
with all access or Prince Charles was
even using the stroller you say Prince
Charles was in this stroke not exactly
mine well he was talking pound kind off
okay he wasn't exactly anyone catalyzed
kind of lag back we have here this small
you get both home from yes yes yes yes
yes
4200 without analysis always an
additional $1,000 for the small one
which are a small baby girl can push oh
so they can help too
yes so so yeah you're pushing here your
baby and here the don't yes like oh so
you can't put a bit more baby this is
this is a toy this is for dogs it's a
dog
$1,000 to dog yes but it's still just
smiling no and um I think oh hey LEM
nice man so listen let's imagine this
guy in this dress it's pushing this
truck destroy Oh beautiful $200 bear you
know baby can sleep we have here
mattresses so you know your Connie call
your a beautiful house yes very sleeping
still in the stroller because you don't
want to wake up your baby cuz I'm good
parent you don't want to wake him up I
don't know
he's sleeping and it's great decoration
also in your bedroom so everything looks
great so you definitely want to have it
and you must have it five thousand
dollars for a baby carrier yeah and a
teddy bear carry yes for a doll carrier
yes and a hundred and fifteen years old
and Prince Charles was in one kind of
like it exactly okay cool okay cool you
know me man I got the kids
I really appreciated this spot Claudia
you can tell she had some kind of flair
for fashion you can test you as an
expert in making people smile
she said it over and over and over again
can't be mad at that Claudia it was a
pleasure meeting you I cannot wait you
said my son can be the model in your
runway show we're gonna take you up on
that offer what do you think expensive
baby clothes do you think it'll put a
smile on your face